matt peacock gets the start tonight an
emergency start we only found out about
an hour ago taylor widener stayed home
due to some cold like symptoms oh a
double here in the first inning brings
up adam frazier two and one
liner to right center field that's gonna
get down it's a gapper to 413. coming
around to score is tommy pham and
thinking three is frazier
throw goes in that direction they throw
to the plate and frazier's at third base
so an rbi triple for adam frazier and
the padres strike first on top one
nothing as i just mentioned all the base
runners what do you know the first two
hitters for the padres extra base hits
by frasier a nice level swing as well so
both righty
fam pulling to the gap
lefty pulling to the gap is frazier and
the padres are on the board early and
often for the padres fraser at third
base run in for the friars you're at
third base with one out of run in for
san diego and here's jay chronoworth
it's a full count now
line to right field a base hit that'll
score frazier from third and jake
chronoworth drives in frazier to put the
padres on top two to nothing what an
at-bat by jake cronenworth that is
awesome kid was down 0-2 took some
pitches fouled some off and down and in
off the plate turn on it get out of
there cleans it out rbi single that's a
great at-bat on the mount for the padres
is you darvish 23rd start 34 year old
five-time all-star remember we
documented in the uh pre-game show about
you darvis in his last outing seven
strong two runs against these same
diamondbacks over the course of the
season the opponent's only hitting 209
off the veteran right-hander there's
cattell martay
swinging a miss and he strikes out first
k of the night for you darvish oh he
broke out the splitty the split finger
down and away at 90. you can see martay
watch how far out in front he tries to
stay back and reach for it
can't get it one down here in the first
inning rojas at first base and brings up
pavin smith
and a swing and a miss as he strikes out
back-to-back strikeouts for darvish two
down down and away is the target
it's up and away with the breaking ball
and once again very very late on that
swing david peralta coming up
lying to right but right at myers who
makes the catch almost over his head and
the side is retired no runs couple of
hits and the diamondbacks then at the
corners and myers leads off the second
oh matt peacock with a good slider there
gets his second strikeout real good
slider that time outer third of the
plate with a lot of downward movement at
88 miles an hour meyers right over the
top of that one
and that is going to be it for matt
peacock who will leave after only 29
pitches and what apparently tonight
will be a bullpen ball game
that peacock got the emergency start
he'll go
only four outs holding the bullpen goes
out for caleb smith
who was back in a relief roll after
another rough start
against these padres that was saturday
at san diego five earned runs three hits
he lasted only one and a third he walked
six and so now he's back at a relief for
old train grisham will be the first
batter he faces
what a good start for caleb smith gets
the strikeout that's out number two good
hard fastball 93 right out near the
outside corner that time to grisham i
think a lot of left-handed hitters that
have success against left-handed
pitchers is because they're good
breaking ball hitters caratini against
left handers hitting 281 compared to
only 210 against righties
well two different diamondback pitchers
strike out the side in the second
one two three it's two nothing san diego
two on nobody out here for the
diamondbacks in the third inning
chop
right side and hosmer can apply the tag
got him runners do advance pretty
unassisted on the put out osmo had to go
any further for that he may not have
been able to get the tag himself you
know what's nice about this watch how
this ball checks up towards the first
base line on that second bounce what
went that way yeah it kind of helps eric
hosmer in applying the tag right there
he did swipe him on the back see it
right here love oh i don't know second
and third one out haven smith the
strikeout victim his first time
haven sends it out to right
myers won't get there head drops in for
a base hit to tie the ball game haven
hustles into second and it's two to two
he wasn't struck well but hit in a great
spot this was off the outside corner of
the plate haven hits it off the very end
of the bat but it got out there in right
field and died in front of will myers
easy score that time for caleb smith not
much to think about it right behind him
josh rojas to tie it up carson kelly
singled his first time he backs and now
out hit san diego four to three we're
tied at two
carson fights one off and rolls into
right they're gonna send pavon smith
meyer's throw here it comes it's offline
and the diamondbacks have the lead maybe
an aggressive send right there by tony
paris chica pavon smith is not the
fastest ever base runner hey when a
team's having trouble scoring runs
that's when the third base coach gets
that arm windmill they gotta find a way
to get guys on the plate sometimes you
have to take a little bit of a chance
haven smith was on the bag at third when
will myers picked up that ball his throw
is not even close to home plate and the
d-back take the lead david peralta down
2-2
peralta gets it in the air deep to right
field myers looking up hits in
the freight train sends one out of here
and it's five to two
they have put up a five spot on you
darvish in the third well that's a bat
the diamondbacks desperately need to get
going
89 up and out over the plate david
barrels it right out in front of home
plate sends it into the pool in right
center field it's been a while
myers was hoping for a carom that one's
wet on the fly out there
the sixth of the year for peralta looks
like that's going to be it for darvish
you darvish leaves this game with an
apparent injury you don't want to make
matters worse whatever the case may be
and here's the last pitch kind of
slipped a little bit on that front foot
then he looked down and they'll work
left on left to pave and smith with the
bases full and one out a chance to bust
this thing wide open right here 2-1 and
sliced out to left field trying to get
down and it gets in there for a base hit
caleb is home rojas right behind two
more rbis for pavement smith and it's
seven to two david has knocked in four
no trouble scoring on that hit to short
left field seven two diamondbacks carson
kelly has singled twice he's knocked in
a run
arson kelly sends one to left field hats
off the wall martay will score
haven smith stops at third carson kelly
is three for three just missed a home
one out there
make it eight
osmer hits it hard to second base could
be too well they'll get the out there
and hurt on the play it looked like was
rojas coming in to score is machado and
it's eight to three you get the out at
second base of chronoworth four to six
on the force out and hasbro pick up an
rbi and reach onto fielder's choice the
chance for rojas now
aces full in the eighth inning is
already three for three tonight
second base
frazier knocks it down walker's home
here comes ellis this will score two
more and it's ten to three what a night
for josh
a chance for josh van meter to get in
the head column he wanted two out
there it is it's into center
peralta coming around third walker stops
at second
rbi for van meter it's 11-3 it's 3-0 on
hager
slacks has walked in a run there's the
rbi put that in your back pocket 12-3
trying to snap before a game losing
streak take the opener here first of
four against the padres let's put this
one away right here three and two on
o'grady
lift it out to right center field could
tell martay
has got it diamondbacks with it
12-3 all diamondbacks tonight and what a
night for the offense